from the mine that brought you or paint
freezing hot confirmed kills and elder
millennial you don't see a bachelorette
party coming fucking hearing - and if
you're hearing it don't shoot till you
see the whites of their wines comes the
terrifying truth about getting married
getting there is not that much fun
you're not allowed to say that
especially if you're a woman god forbid
over 30 like well you're just lucky that
the Lord sent you someone to put up with
your shit you have to provide a cocktail
hour for your guests a party that you're
paying for that you're not invited to my
wedding planner was like so did you want
to do like that boy stur bar they can
eat corn dogs and wait in their cars
forget saving the date save yourself
forever
a meisa unveiled
you